so here's a quick problem for you and
this is a perfect illustration of
mentally assisted versus paper assisted
versus calculator system now because you
got a calculator on your desk you may be
tempted to go straight to the calculator
with this okay
and eventually we will punch this into
our calculator to verify that we're
right do you guys remember think back to
the first lesson right
the X is not important to me I mean the
answers useful but it's about how we get
there that's what this is about
okay so I know we have this particularly
from primary school we have this urge to
jump to the answer to jump to the
airtime don't do that it's not the most
important part it's how you get there
that matters so let's have a go like
this the first strategy I'm gonna teach
you is managing a is estimation or
rounding okay now you let this last year
here's what I'm going to do okay I'm
gonna take that line 50 plus 37 plus 18
is over and I'm going to use my
knowledge of approximation we learn how
to approximate these and significant
figures last yeah so let me jog your
memory again why is it useful it's to
say equals I'm gonna say this is
approximately equals okay so it's a
weekly equal sign right so what I'm
gonna have on the right hand side will
not be exactly equal to what I haven't
left but it'll be close and in real life
often that's all we need right we just
need it to be pretty close okay I give
you an example
you guys legend that PI lost you when
you did circles okay you will know that
pi it's this long number here it's one
of those crazy rational numbers that we
were talking about before yeah your
calculator no it's not a set but is
irrational
all these decimal places they go off
forever and you might think wow if I
want to be accurate and precise I'll
need a whole bunch right well even civil
engineers you have to build buildings
they need to stand up they only use that
much of the number
a tiny proportion of the whole thing but
it's enough okay and that's what I'm
gonna do here I'm going to approximate
these numbers one by one and we'll see
what I get
so 15 if I round that off to one
significant figures got two at the
moment the one in the five what would it
be to one significant figure it'll be
twenty that's exactly right because I
want this to be zero and 5 is more five
back funny kids it goes off doesn't it
okay so I ran both to twenty thirty
seven if I want one significant figure
it's gonna go up to forty I'm gonna keep
going
eighteens gonna go up to twenty little
pores remember I'm trying to estimate
this right now normally I'd say the
forty five should go up to fifty right
ah but hold on hold on
I made this one go up so wouldn't it be
helpful for me because I'm just
estimating it's round it wouldn't be
helpful for this to actually go down
because then they'll kind of balance
each other out does that make sense so
I'm gonna write that one as forty and
then you got twenty two on the end and
that's going to be 20 okay now have a
look at this this is ten times easier to
do than this
right all of the zeros don't really
matter right because if I go 2 plus 4 is
6 plus 2 is 8 plus 4 is 12 plus another
2 is 14 and then I put all of the zeros
on 140 now that's not exactly right but
it is very close and often close enough
is all I need
okay and that was strategy 1 let's go
strategy 2 and get something for size
without your calculators okay do you
remember last year we learnt something
called the commutated mole
it does sound which is not a coincidence
by the way now the commutator vol is
very simple it means that some
operations it doesn't matter what order
you do them in you can do them front to
back or back to front and it's all the
same okay
now there are two operations we know
about that are commutator where you can
change the order what are the two
operations yep multiplication and
addition right 3 times 5 is the same as
5 times 3 they're both 15 and a D I
could change the order here to help me
ok so watch and I'm gonna ask you guys
to put your laptop in still that did
pass before cuz I was just waiting to
see how self-disciplined you were but I
have waited and I've made my judgment
well done Daniel ok have a look at this
with you see this you okay write it down
again but I'm going to reorder it in a
way that makes it easy for me ok because
some orders are easier than others
I'll give you an example have a look at
these two
if I pair these two together because
there's a 5 and a 5 there right my
daughter who's a new one would call
these friends of 10 right 5 5 they're
gonna add up to 10 right sir I'm gonna
say equals this is gonna be exact right
I'm gonna put the 15 and the 45 together
I didn't have to put the brackets but it
makes it obvious to me what I'm
combining I've got those two can someone
else tell me what's another thing I
should pair up yeah fantastic here's the
2 and 1/8 which are friends of 10 right
so if I could buy these guys that's also
going to be easy
one last number that's left over
all right help me out 50 plus 45 16 18
plus 22 40 and that's the 37 on the end
now that's easy as well that's a hundred
137 exact no calculators required